je suis ta pièce d'une soute effet je
vais pas reculer alors le son est
tellement fils ça fait suer c'est dans
le même sens que le le dernier daft punk
alors comme un blu ray ce matin pour me
reprendre leur hockey j'essaie de régler
ça q quand je mangeais sont un peu le
mandat comme un favori bouge toi tu toi
tu vas pas qu'il est en galère la secte
est devenu sérieux
franklin tu mets des coups de pression
avoue d'équipements non non mais le guen
a pas de noms mais ouais ce qu'est ce
qui t'arrive
je dois ça fait dix ans je travaille
avec lui tu veux lui apprendre son
métier
vas-y par ces lieux web or jeudi
l'annoncé des parties en plus je devais
aller voir un autre cousin a causé un
vitry ça vraiment content du tout
regarde alors maison raison [ __ ]
franklin et tapantes